early in the pandemic when trump was
president you all remember when trump
was president right and uh he was early
on like march april
february march april of 2020
it really seemed to us
to me i'll just speak for myself
like he was screwing everything up about
his response to sorry's kobe 2 and uh
march 20th i think 23rd something right
in there was actually the first
darkhorse live stream that we did and it
was in direct response to us seeing this
just like crazy public messaging that
was happening and so we started these
live streams specifically to
try to provide a scientific analysis of
what made sense what was what appeared
to be entirely political but in the
guise of science and what appeared to be
what was actually going on
and um
you know we got a lot right and we got a
few things wrong and i think we've come
back to you guys when we did make errors
in the moment and
and
um here's one thing though that we
haven't come back to you with yet which
is because we didn't we didn't get it
wrong so much it was like it was an
error of omission rather than commission
at the point that trump said whatever he
did about hydra to support us like this
video subscribe to the channel and
consider writing a comment and because
1984 has captured 2021 click the link in
the description to see the full clip on
odyssey
[Music]
you